So today I'd like to talk about how we
find disease-causing mutations.
This is going to rely on a computational
problem known as read mapping.
And to get to that, I'd like to first
talk about the simple
fact that the cost of sequencing a
genome has decreased exponentially over
the past decade.
According to NIH, in 2001, it cost about
$100,000,000
to sequence a human genome
In 2013
that's well below $10,000, and there's a
hope that we'll soon see
the $1,000 genome.
As genome sequencing has gotten cheaper,
biologists
have moved from wanting to answer large
scale questions about species comparison
using genomes
towards using personal genomes to answer
biological questions.
So, we move from a generic average case
human being
to specific humans: me, Pavel, and Son,
and we want to
say what is it that makes us unique as
humans individually.
So if we look at our genomes, they are
largely similar, right?
We only have small variations for the most
part.
And the most common type of mutation,
causing these variations, is a
single nucleotide variation.
So, we may see a substitution where in the
same position we might see a C, an A, or a T.
OK?
So, the question then would be why do we
care about this?
And there's many different reasons why we
want to do personal genomics.
Probably, the most popular one is
that they
can help us with identifying the basis of
genetic diseases.
Son and Pavel mentioned in the assembly
talk, that in 2010 this
child Nicholas Volker became the first
human being to have his life
saved because of genome sequencing.
They were able to use gene therapy
after having performed a number of
unsuccessful surgeries.
And so the hope is that this is going to
be the future of medicine.
That we'll be able to identify genetic
issues, using
an individual genome, and use these to
design effective treatments.
Again, as the cost of sequencing a genome
has decreased, we're
now seeing large scale projects to
sequence huge numbers of genomes.
So in the UK there's a personal genome
project with a
goal that's recently launched with a goal
of sequencing 100,000 human genomes.
Of course, it's not a central focus of
what we want to talk about
тoday we want to talk about a
computational problem today
but when we start talking about a huge
number of genomes like this, there are a
number of ethical issues.
So for example, what if you had your
genome sequenced and you found out
that you had a high probability of getting
some genetic disorder later in life.
Would your employer be able to fire you
because
of that, because they wouldn't want to
keep you around?
And in the US we actually
have had Congress pass the Genetic
Nondiscrimination Act
of 2008, which said that employers are
not able to do this, right?
If they find out genetic information,
they're not able to prevent
you from getting health insurance or fire
you without a good reason.
So, we want to move again as I said
towards a computational problem.
And the computational problem is going to
work as follows.
Once we've sequenced a human genome we can
now have a reference genome.
So we have a genome in a database that we
can compare against
since we know that all human genomes are
very similar.
So our question is, how is it that
we can assemble individual genomes now
efficiently, using the
reference genome information that we
already have?
The question would be then, why don't we
use assembly, right?
We've learned a lot about algorithms in
this course.
We have a huge arsenal of different
methods
that we can use, to answer questions on
bioinformatics.
So, maybe the most obvious, solution that
we would do would
be to say let's just sequence let's
assemble the individual genome
from scratch, and then once we have
assembled back using the
assembly methods that we already know, we
can compare it against the
reference genome, and identify places
where the variance occur.
That's a perfectly reasonable way of
looking at the problem, but traditionally
constructing a de Bruijn graph or to
assemble a genome from
scratch, that's something that takes a lot
of memory, our hope is
that we can use the information that's
stored in the reference genome.
If we have, if each individual
has 99% similarity with the reference
genome
then we shouldn't need to start from
scratch.
We should be able to use the
information that's in that reference
to help us assemble each new individual
genome.
So our end hope would be, maybe you could
go into a clinic and have your
genome sequenced in 10 minutes using the
reference
that it would collect and map your reads.
Now what do I mean by mapping reads?
By read mapping we mean that we want to
determine where each
read, so each read that's generated by the
sequencing machine, has high similarity
to the reference gene.
OK, so rather than assembling from
scratch,
we're going to take each of your
sequencing
reads, and we're going to say where is
this read most similar to the reference
genome?
And, is there any variation there?
So we might see a perfect
sub-string match here.
We might see a substitution here, and we
may see a deletion there.
We're going to focus on a simpler question
though, which is going to help us
generalize the
problem, which is where is it that the
sequencing reads from your genome,
where is it that they match the reference
genome exactly?
If we can answer this question, then maybe
we can generalize it.
OK?
And so, if we're given a single read,
then this corresponds to a problem that
we've already
seen back at the start of the class, which
was the pattern matching problem for a
single pattern.
So, you're given a string pattern, that
represents a read.
And then a larger string genome.
And you want to figure out which
positions
that pattern matches the genome as a
sub-string.
So, all we're doing then,
is generalizing this to multiple reads, on
multiple patterns.
We're finding, given a collection of
patterns, where is
that those patterns match exactly in the
larger genome?
We, you probably implemented a brute force
approach to the pattern
matching problem in chapter 1 if you
solved the code challenge there.
And probably the way that you did it was
to slide the pattern down the genome.
And so if you had a pattern nana and you
were looking in the
genome panamabananas, now we're going to
use
words or things that are close to words.
So we're going to use like, the structure
of English, so that
I don't have to say a, c, g, t, t, g, g,
g because this is a string problem.
OK?
So we're going to assume that genome is
panamabananas, and
this is an example that will come back to.
And so, say that we have this hypothetical
read nana.
If we want to find the exact matches, then
we simply slide it down.
We see in the first position, p and n
don't match, so we slide it down,
a and n don't match, and then in the third
position we see a match of n.
OK?
And so, we say, well let's move to the
second position,
we see two matches.
The third position we don't match and so
we
can slide the pattern down to the
next position.
No match, no match, no match, no match.
And then we finally reach an n again, and
we see that there is a pattern match
there.
And then we're at the end of the string.
So, this seems like a perfectly reasonable
approach.
We take each pattern and we just slide it
down the genome.
And find out where the pattern matches.
So I think maybe we can call it a day
early today.
Or at least on this problem maybe we can
start
going ahead and generalizing from
the exact pattern matching problem.
But I think we've got a perfectly
reasonable way of solving a multiple
matching problem.